wenn der robert die anna lena der
christian und erfolgreicher sich gerade
treffen dann haben sie offenbar zu aller
erst mal eine richtig gute zeit
[Musik]
und dann klingt es danach immer als
hätten sie gerade gemeinsam in billy
regal zusammengeschraubt die schraube
schräg einsetzen wird sie nie wieder
gerade diese frau bist in den ersten
tagen sehr gerade eingesetzt worden
baumarkt der politik und wir schauen
jetzt mal wie genau läuft das denn
gerade mit den verhandlungen zur
regierungsbildung
beim sondieren testen die parteien also
erst mal an mit wem könnte es sich denn
überhaupt lohnen koalitionsverhandlungen
aufzunehmen da geht es erst mal um das
grundsätzliche nach dem motto ja wir
waren politische gegner aber können wir
uns vorstellen dass wir trotzdem
irgendwie miteinander können wir gucken
uns heute mal an welches bündnis die
besten chancen hat wie man in der
politik überhaupt richtig verhandelt und
was man aus dem jamaica scheitern von
2017 lernen kann und jetzt geht's los
wer kann mit wem und wer kann mit wem
gar nicht lindner ist ein luftikus hat
kevin kühnert das ist der jungstar der
spd noch kurz vor der wahl gesagt jetzt
müssen spd und fdp auch wieder zusammen
am tisch sitzen während claudia roth von
den grünen und die fdp frau
strack-zimmermann sich im fernsehen
schon die ghetto faust geben und sagen
wenn wir beide regieren dann
legalisieren wir auf jeden fall cannabis
sofort
ja aber bei diesen verhandlungen steht
natürlich mehr auf dem spiel als die
zukunft von cannabis und deswegen habe
ich mir einen echten
verhandlungsexperten an die seite geholt
nämlich jack national und der weiß alles
über die richtige taktik bei solchen
schwierigen politischen gesprächen jan
adamus muss man sich mögen um zu guten
ergebnissen zu kommen überhaupt nicht
man muss sie nicht mögen man muss sich
nur respektieren und gerade politiker
wissen das weil da wird natürlich beim
wahlkampf wird auch mit sehr harten
bandagen gespielt danach sitzt man
zusammen so ist das halt ja hauptsache
mannschaft das vertrauen aufzubauen in
diesen aller ersten gesprächen und
vertraulichkeit auch ganz wichtig
[Musik]
mit diesem sexy hier ihr habt alle
gesehen könnte tatsächlich was ganz
neues beginnen berber und harbeck
witzigen und lindner treffen sich zum
allerersten mal und zwar ohne vorher die
presse zu informieren frechheit und
posten danach alle das gleiche foto da
steckt natürlich ganz viel message denn
erstens wir können dicht halten zweitens
ohne uns geht hier gar nichts mehr und
drittens wir effekten das format
politischer gespräche ganz neu und bei
der ersten pressekonferenz danach war
ich auch vor ort und habe gefragt wie
geht das mit dem sondieren können sie
mal ein bisschen sagen wie sie taktisch
davor gehen in diesen gesprächen sagen
sie an mit den themen wo sie er sowieso
schon nah beieinander sind wo es
einfacher ist und lassen die schwierigen
themen wie steuerpolitik erst für den
ganz für den schluss oder wie wie geht
man davor wir sind heute schmallippig
auch dazu kommen wir heute nichts
weiteres sagen jr gibt eine
pressekonferenz und könnte danach nichts
sagen dasselbe kamen danach in varianten
noch mehrfach dazu möchten wir nicht
sagen wir haben sehr vertrauensvolle
gespräche und zum gemeinsamen
prozess gehört eben auch dass wir nicht
fortwährend zwischenergebnisse und
wasserstandsmeldungen nach draußen geben
so haben wir uns auch vereinbart und
daran werden wir drei uns vor allem
halbjahr der verhandlungs profi jack
nasher sagt genau so geht's es ist
unheimlich wichtig weil wenn ihr
publikum haben in verhandlung werden wir
viel aggressiver das heißt wenn die
ganze zeit leute gucken dann wird es
sehr sehr schwierig wenn ich die ganze
zeit sage wo die verhandlungsposition
ist er auf keinen fall um das empfehle
ich ihnen wirklich haltet die klappe
sagt es nicht weil das euch viel
schwächer macht in der verhandlung war
da müsst ihr immer noch das euren
anderen den anderen verkaufen der
öffentlichkeit verkaufen und das macht
die verhandlungen fast unmöglich der
grund ist klar nein steckt noch dieses
2017 in den knochen alles soll diesmal
anders besser laufen als bei diesen
jämmerlich gescheiterten jamaika
verhandlungen da war nämlich nichts mit
vertraulichkeit
[Musik]
damals trafen sich union fdp und grüne
über 50 tage lang in der noblen
parlamentarischen vertretung direkt
gegenüber vom bundestag und hier in
diesem raum mit den weißen schweren
tisch decken wurden dann die langen
langen listen mit forderungen in der
einzelnen parteien punkt für punkt
abgearbeitet die balkon pausen waren
legendär da wurde für die fotografen
immer draußen friede freude eierkuchen
inszeniert was das zeug hält und wir
journalisten wir standen draußen in der
kälte
stundenlang ab und so kam eine sms von
einem pressesprecher oder ein politiker
unter hieß es dann also dieses und jenes
ist jetzt geeint aber dies und das ist
noch strittig das ging oft bis tief in
die nacht und am ende als immer noch 237
punkte offen waren dass mit christian
lindner handys ist besser nicht zu
regieren als falsch zu regieren wer
damals auch stinksauer war er hier das
war ein ganz fürchterlicher tag will man
nicht noch mal erleben über viele viele
stunden in kleinen gruppen in großen
gruppen hin und her papiere gemacht eine
gans angespannte atmosphäre und das
hätte eigentlich zu jeder zeit scheitern
können aber als man dann durch war
jeweils ich das gefühl hatte so jetzt
haben wir ein paket geschnürt das kann
das fragen wird das paket gar nicht mehr
verhandelt sondern dann wird der stecker
gezogen und da habe ich schon gedacht
ja kann ich mich allein ja also von
christian lindner weiß man also das ist
einer der staat notfalls auch auf und
geht ich glaube das stimmt nicht mehr
vier jahre später muss die fdp regieren
das kann christian lindner seinen
eigenen leuten nicht noch mal erklären
dass er davon laufen würde und das
wissen natürlich seine
verhandlungspartner heute auch nur für
einen ist er wirklich die letzte
hoffnung
[Musik]
der bundesvorstand das präsidium der cdu
ist sich darin einig dass wir zu
gesprächen für eine sogenannte jamaika
koalition bereit stehen für armin
laschet ist jamaika die letzte chance
kommt das nicht geht er quasi in rente
und die union in die opposition heißt
laschet ist erpressbar mit ihm hätten
fdp und grüne wirklich leichtes spiel
denn die union hat bittsteller status in
diesen sondierungen das kann man nach
den ersten gesprächen ganz gut
heraushören das war ein guter abend das
war ein guter start der lust auf mehr
macht heute war es ein gespräch das
wirklich von großer vertraulichkeit
geprägt war aber auch von großen
inhaltlichen schnittmengen
aber die mehrheit der wähler will gar
keinen jamaika-bündnis und bei fdp und
grünen ist man total irritiert darüber
wie angezählt armin laschet aus den
eigenen reihen gerade ist ich glaube ja
christian lindner hält die jamaika
option nur deswegen noch so ein bisschen
in der schwebe um ein druckmittel zu
haben gegenüber der ampel koalition so
ein bisschen druck gehört ja auch dazu
sagt jack nasher wenn ich richtig froh
dann mache ich das so dann sage ich ja
ich will gerne lasst uns zusammen
hinbekommen weil sonst müssen wir ja
leider ich habe druck eben aus den
eigenen reihen dass wir dann was anderes
machen wie zum beispiel die große
koalition oder neuwahlen oder was auch
immer oder beginnen die opposition
machen uns da gemütlich aber das ist
eben wichtig dass ich sehr wohl
alternativen haben und die auch klar
kommunizieren aber freundlich eben nicht
drohen
[Musik]
die spd dagegen ganz selbstbewusst auf
kanzler kurs wir sind ja klar wir wollen
olaf scholz als kanzler die
sozialdemokraten wollen noch im oktober
mit koalitionsgesprächen beginnen und
stellte in aussicht dass die ampel
regierung bis weihnachten steht das
klingt so easy aber auch das wird nicht
einfach selbst zwischen den
wunschpartnern spd und grünen gibt es
große inhaltliche differenzen denkt noch
mal an den kohleausstieg
2038 das ist den grünen viel zu spät und
der weg von der spd zur fdp der ist noch
viel weiter beispiel finanzen natürlich
war auch klar dass unsere inhaltlichen
positionierungen in wesentlichen punkten
auseinander liegen ja und genau da kommt
es eben auf das richtige verhandeln an
[Musik]
interessant ist dabei so
verhandlungsdelegation immer wie bei
einer guten party wer bringt wen mit und
in diesem fall ist es so die spd kommt
mit sechs leuten fdp grüne cdu bringen
jeweils zehn mit und die cs und bringt
natürlich auch nochmal fünf leute mit
obwohl eigentlich alle wissen das ist
gar keine gute idee ist wenn so viele
mitreden vor vier jahren waren nicht
alle dabei aber die die dabei waren
wissen dass große teams nicht zu einer
besonderen stärke geführt habe und
trotzdem machen sie den gleichen fehler
wieder das heißt für eine ampel würden
also 26 leute verhandeln und für jamaika
sogar sagenhafte 35 also eine gute größe
sind pro team drei bis fünf leute
empfehle ich immer bei sonst gibt es zu
viele verschiedene interessen und wenn
so viele sind muss ganz klar sein der
verhandlungsführer ist wer beobachtet
und wir bett kopf ist die rollen müssen
sehr klar verteilt sein zur
rollenverteilung die spd bringt zum
beispiel in mahlow dreier mit nach
berlin an den verhandlungstisch da fragt
man sich jetzt vielleicht erst mal wieso
das denn was macht die denn da ja das
hat einen grund malu dreyer ist die
rheinland pfälzische ministerpräsident
in und die hat schon 2017 in ihrem land
ein ampelbündnis erfolgreich geschmiedet
und ein grüner der damals dabei war der
hat mir mal erzählt wie das lief
angeblich hat die spd zuerst bei den
klima themen die fdp gegen die grünen
aus gespielt und dann hat sie sich bei
den fdp themen mit den grünen verbündet
das heißt malu dreyer weiß
offensichtlich sehr genau wie dieses
schachspiel verhandlungen funktioniert
und deswegen ist jetzt in berlin dabei
aber fdp und grüne haben aus solchen
situationen natürlich auch gelernt
deshalb jetzt auch all diese
vorgespräche immer wieder die betonung
dass man zusammen stärker sei als union
und spd und ganz wichtig auch brücken
suchen
[Musik]
ein guter verhandler sucht immer erst
mal das verbindende die brücken von
denen jetzt immer wieder die rede ist
und baut dann gar auf auf also brücken
stellt gleich rote linien ziehen und für
jede partei muss am ende was raus
springen für die eigene wählerklientel
irgendwas muss im koalitionsvertrag sich
finden wo jede partei sagen kann das
steht ja nur weil wir es wollten also
ich muss als verhandler sozusagen immer
die victory speed der anderen schreiben
ich muss mir immer überlegen wie kann
sie jetzt vor ihre wähler treten um
stolz verkünden was sie alles geschafft
hat und das ist das a und o also ich
muss überlegen wie kann sie es verkaufen
und diese argumente muss ich ihr mit an
die hand geben das könnte bei der ampel
dann zum beispiel so aussehen die spd
kriegt ihre zwölf euro mindestlohn für
die fdp einigen sich alle darauf dass
die schuldenbremse eingehalten wird und
die grünen setzten durch dass solar und
windkraft schneller ausgebaut werden so
wird glaube ich gerade auch geredet dass
die sachen nicht durchgestochen werden
dass man ernsthaft ring dass man auch
versucht mit zu denken was ist denn das
projekt des jeweils anderen und wie kann
man da war es vielleicht die gemeinsame
erzählung machen hört sich für mich erst
mal sehr guten und jetzt fragt ihr euch
vielleicht wie will denn christian
lindner seinen wählern erklären dass die
versprochene steuerentlastung nicht
sofort kommt ganz einfach lindner deutet
jetzt schon an das müsste ja nicht alles
sofort kommen wichtig sei dass man jetzt
in eine entlastung jahrzehnt gehen das
heißt also nichts anderes als die fdp
strikt einfach ihr wahlversprechen ein
bisschen ja das sind so die strategien
und zwei sachen sind noch wichtig zum
einen stunden lange nachtsitzungen
verhandeln bis einer vor erschöpfung
einschläft dass wir keine mehr und das
bringt auch gar nichts und über posten
sollte man erst ganz zum schluss reden
erst das land dann die partei dann die
person in der reihenfolge das heißt wer
finanzminister wird darüber müsst ihr
euch später streiten christian robert
okay
[Musik]
also dann schauen wir mal was sie sich
für eine regierung für uns zurecht
verhandeln wenn ihr politisch
interessiert seid dann haben wir weitere
tolle videos für euch bei insight
politics empfiehlt uns weiter abonniert
uns liegt uns und wenn ihr fragen habt
schreibt gerne unten in die kommentare